hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about
tech career and life today's video is
the last and final part of a three-part
resume video series where i critique my
own resumes from the past
in the first video i could change like
my first ever resume
and in the second one i reviewed the one
that got me my first
real software engineering internship and
so finally today i'm going to be showing
you
my critique of the resume that got me my
job
at a startup in silicon valley called
patreon and for my job at
netflix so like the other two videos
maybe number one you're watching this
video to get some inspiration
on how to format and write your own
resume
or number two you're just nosy you're a
little bit curious and you just want to
know what my resume looked like
and maybe there's like a third and final
part i don't know but i'm excited that
you're here
so let's get started
moving on to resume number three so this
resume was written
in the spring of 2016 so this was a few
years after the previous one
i was switching jobs out of into it and
this was a resume that i used to
apply to patreon as you can see it's
just like
so much more simpler than my previous
ones like the margins are fine it's not
like
completely packed with information um
but i do still have a couple of
critiques about this one
so i start with my name and then i write
ios software engineer
because at this point i know what
specific part of software engineering i
want to go into
and so i thought it was really important
for me to write that on this resume
i've got my contact info on the left
side which i think is like a pretty good
use of space
and then i do this whole like two column
stuff which i was experimenting with
which
i think went well except for um
just the header lines are really hard to
read like i write what my role was
the program the application the company
and my duration all in one line which is
just like
it's impossible to read this i also am
just like completely missing bullet
points on this which
i think i actually added them in but the
color i think is just so faded that it
doesn't show up in print format
one thing that i remember i did for this
resume that i was like so proud of
was that the colors that i used for this
resume
are the default colors in xcode which is
the official ide for ios development
i thought that was kind of clever
because i was like hey look at me
i'm like an apple person i'm one of
y'all let's
like show you this through like the
colors that i used in my resume so it
kind of just looks like you're looking
at your xcode ide and it looks a little
bit more familiar
i have no idea whether that worked at
all or not or like if anybody else
appreciated it but
i liked it and i thought that was cool
in this resume i finally got
way more specific about the work that i
did so saying things like designed and
implemented the view model for business
logic that integrated with the model and
apis
and thoroughly tested using unit and
integration tests like as an ios
engineer i know exactly what that means
and i can kind of imagine what that work
was
and so it gives me a sense of like okay
this is the exact work that she did
and that comes through to me very
clearly the only place that i feel like
i wasn't specific enough was when i
talked about
driving various technology spikes to
explore and assess different
technologies and its implications
i would have liked to know like what
kinds of technologies did you explore
at the time react native was really big
and so i think as a recruiter it would
have been cool to see like what other
technologies within
or outside of ios were you able to
experiment with
and have knowledge about because yeah
the time everyone was like should i go
into react native should i not like
should we have a bit of the app be in
react native so there's not much more to
highlight about the work experience part
i think i solved a lot of the issues
from before in this one
and then in the skills part i just
wanted to highlight it says excellent
teamwork and communication skills
no longer diplomatic teamwork and
communication skills
i talk about awards that i've won which
i won an award for
like a internal hackathon thing uh
called the intuit create the offering
innovation award but it was
entirely internal and so one note that i
have for myself is like
what is it like what is this conference
what is this award what did you make for
it
um i think i would have liked to know a
little bit more because
chances are the recruiter whoever is
looking at the resume didn't want to get
into it and has no idea what this award
is
so yeah unless it's like an award that
people just like have heard of and it's
common and stuff i think it's important
to elaborate
what exactly that thing was so yeah
that's resume number three
this is the resume that got me into
patreon uh and
i i think it's very nice i've i'm very
fond of this one
especially the color part just gets me
um
but i'm pretty proud of this one
uh hold up real quick so while i did
turn in my resume to netflix i actually
didn't cold apply to netflix like i did
my other jobs
i actually got into the interviewing
process through networking with one of
the engineering managers for the ios
team
so i actually don't give this resume
that much credit but i turned it in and
they didn't say no
i actually think this kind of attests to
the power of networking for getting a
job in the tech industry
but i just wanted to put it out there as
a disclaimer now we get into my most
recent resume which i used to apply to
netflix
so i was getting kind of bored of just
like the text based format at this point
and so i downloaded a resume template
which i thought looked really cool
but honestly my first impression of this
is literally i wrote this on the bottom
the layout sucks uh i think for many
reasons
number one the spacing is kind of weird
it's actually supposed to be on a longer
piece of paper and so when it's on this
it's like kind of smushed
and there's like weird margins that
happen the colors
i probably wouldn't opt for this kind of
color uh if i was to print on stuff
but also at this time i feel like
resumes weren't often
printed and instead they were often sent
through
job portals or pdfs and stuff and so it
didn't really matter at the time but
now that i'm looking at it on paper i'm
like ugh it's like ugly
which you never know if a recruiter is
going to print your resume so maybe it's
good to like
have something that works for both a pdf
format and a print format
and then yeah the margins like why
why why are the margins all so gross
like
um i liked this resume because i like
put a picture of myself which a lot of
people say it's not necessary but
i don't know i like being able to like
put a name to a face when i'm looking at
other resumes
and i also put a little bit of an about
section to talk a little bit more about
what my passions are and why i'm in
technology
which i think is important to talk about
my experience takes up the most
of this resume um and at this point i
had worked a patreon for a couple years
and so
i wrote down a lot of the stuff that i
worked on so feedback that i have though
is that i say i re-architected major
parts of the app to be more flexible
extensible and testable
i would ask like how like how did you do
that what specific
architectures did you adopt or patterns
did you
introduce into the app that helps it to
do that and then i say reduce the bug
backlog by 43
in two months which they say you should
put like data
in your resume to show that like you can
make results but i'm just like
how like how did you reduce it did you
fix all of them did you triage it
because that's a big difference
i know what the answer is i triage them
but i just wanted numbers on my resume
so i just did that
and then the last thing was i say
introduce scrum on project team by
educating and implementing the practice
and serve as scrum master or coordinator
i think that's fine as it is actually
but i
maybe would have said something more
along the lines of
helped the team to adopt the scrum
methodology
and like onboard them instead of having
it sound like i
forced scrum on them because it was a
mutual decision
but i think the language could have been
a little bit more massaged there
so yeah like my experience into it is a
little bit more condensed than the
previous one
i write my skills which are way more
specific to ios development at this
point
and this is the first time that i
highlighted my youtube channel
so yeah this is actually my most recent
resume i kind of need to make a new one
which includes my experience at netflix
which maybe i'll make into another video
about my
most recent resume but these
four resumes have been a really
important part of my career and
it was really fun to kind of like go
through them and critique them
so i think one of the really important
lessons we've learned in critiquing
resumes and looking at my resumes is
that it's really just
important to get experience and build
skills and one way to do that is through
the plethora of online courses out there
which is where i wanted to thank the
sponsor of today's video brilliant
brilliant is a problem-solving based
website and app with a hands-on approach
with over 60 interactive courses in math
science and computer science
all of brilliant courses have
storytelling code writing
interactive challenges and problems to
solve i really
like the way that brilliant does this
because the concepts stick and it feels
like you're actually gaining skill
through doing their courses
like maybe you're interviewing for jobs
right now they have an algorithms
interactive solvables course
as well as a computer science
fundamentals course
so make sure to check out brilliant and
go to brilliant.org
hello myuco for 20 off an annual premium
subscription today
all right everybody thank you so much
for watching this video i hope you
enjoyed this one and the two
others if you haven't caught those ones
i'll leave it in the description box
down below
make sure to subscribe to my channel for
more tech career and lifestyle videos
and i will see you next time
bye